here's moscow's largest airport about a
year ago
here's the airport last week
the biggest difference there are more
planes
some of them shouldn't be here but most
of those planes aren't leaving the
country
more than 400 aircraft owned by Foreign
leasing companies are stuck in Russia
after President Vladimir Putin signed a
law allowing Airlines to take control of
the planes in response to Western
sanctions the aircraft which are valued
at 10 billion dollars are now caught in
a battle between Russia and the west
where both are trying to use the planes
to punish the other so why is Russia
holding on to these planes how does
their seizure affect the west and what
are the Ripple effects of this fight on
the broader aviation industry
in response to Russia's invasion of
Ukraine Western companies leveled a long
list of sanctions against the country
and directly targeted its aviation
industry from sanctions Banning
shipments on spare parts and new planes
to this we will join our allies in
closing off American airspace to all
Russian flights further isolating Russia
and adding additional squeezed on their
economy all of these things are really
designed to put Russia's aviation
industry on Siege among the sanctions
was a requirement for Western leasing
companies to cancel contracts with
Russian Airlines and get their planes
back and that's a big deal Western
leasing companies own 70 of Russia's 981
Jetson service or in storage if all of
those aircraft will return the domestic
system within Russia would collapse but
Russia wasn't always as reliant on
Western aircraft here's a Russian tu-114
seen on a testing flight before the
1990s Soviet Union era aircraft ruled
Russian Skies but when the Soviet Union
collapsed the market opened up and the
need for new aircraft grew rather than
buying Boeing or Airbus planes Russian
carriers leased them these aircraft
helped open up Russian Airlines like
National carrier aeroflot to the West
this is what we've seen over the last
two decades is really Russia's aviation
industry transforming itself from kind
of a Soviet era you know reputation into
greatly more of a world-class
competitive industry and that's really
all been pretty much undone by the
invasion of this actions that are
followed under the sanctions Boeing
Airbus and their suppliers are
prohibited from sending parts and doing
maintenance on the lease planes that
make up much of Russia's commercial
Fleet while this may not have an
immediate impact it could have a lasting
one what that means is that over time
the safety record of Russia's Airlines
is going to degrade right you're going
to have aircraft that aren't maintained
to the standards that they they are
meant to be while Russia does
manufacture a few aircraft domestically
cerium data shows much of those planes
rely on Western built engines and parts
the country can't get so what can
Russian Airlines do
racing reports and you know comments
from the Russian government that they
had for example approached China to try
and find other ways of bringing in spare
parts it sounds initially like China
hasn't been willing to be after that
kind of support for the Russian Airlines
but a deal with China still wouldn't
cover Parts manufactured by Boeing and
Airbus for those experts say Russia will
likely end up cannibalizing aircraft
basically using some planes as part
spins to keep others operational it's
not quite clear what the long-term
solution is and there's only so many
times that you can do that it's expected
that you know within the next couple
years this will have a serious impact
meanwhile the seized aircraft are
creating issues for the West Russia
responded to the airspace closures by
doing the same which has raised the
question can the least aircraft actually
be recovered easy answer is no it is it
is not possible according to cerium
nearly 80 planes have been returned so
far but those were taken back outside of
Russia Putin's move to seize planes
inside the country has created a
multi-billion dollar problem for leasing
companies and their insurers it's almost
like weaponizing the value of these
aircraft because it's going to become a
an insurance issue with the lessors that
issue who's going to pay for these
planes they're valued at about 10
billion dollars but experts say the
insured value is even more perhaps as
much as 15 billion while none of the
leasing companies rely solely on the
Russian Market writing off billions
isn't something they want to do
if all of those aircraft were written
off it's it's not a great day for
lessors but it wouldn't put a single
less oil out of business leasing
companies could instead pass the cost on
to their insurers where the effect could
cause more harm the biggest issue here
is that I can't find anyone in the
industry who thinks the engine the the
insurance Market can withstand a 15
billion dollar claim industry Executives
have said that this could lead to
litigation that may take years to
resolve or to requests for government
support meanwhile experts say the
confidence Western companies had in
working in the Russian Market has eroded
I think it'll be very difficult for the
lessors to and and even more broader
industry to return to Russia for years
the extent to which any long-term
effects will be felt depends on how long
Russia continues to wage war in Ukraine
even if the invasion is resolved
relatively quickly is still likely to be
this loss of damage not only on the
brands of these Russian Airlines but
also on their relationships with with
their Western Partners but the sanctions
have already begun to take a toll a
spokeswoman from moscow's largest
airport said this week that the airport
had furloughed 20 percent of its
employees as activity at the airport has
declined by approximately 70 percent and
while these Gates look active these
terminals are now closed that's
definitely something that the sanctions
are designed to do is to put pressure on
the domestic Aviation travel industry in
Russia and kind of the knock-on impact
that that has on the economy
[Music]